I want to begin this hour
with breaking news out of Japan.
A Japan Airlines plane burst into flames
after it collided
with a Japanese Coast Guard
aircraft on the runway. In Tokyo.
This new video shows the moment of impact
after the passenger
jet landed at the airport just hours ago.
And you can see in the video
the Japan Airlines plane
bursting into flames
as it goes down the runway there.
Five crew members on the Coast
Guard plane were killed.
The captain is in critical condition.
The crew were preparing
to fly to western Japan
to try to help with earthquake relief.
Nearly 400 passengers and crew
were on the Japan Airlines flight.
They were able to escape.
17 people reportedly were hurt.
Let's bring in CNN's Will Ripley.
He joins us live from Tokyo.
So what's the latest here?
What are you learning
Well, just within the last
couple of hours,
the Japanese prime minister
sending his condolences to the families
of those five Coast Guard crew members.
The Coast Guard has a base
right next to the Honda Airport,
which sits in the heart of Tokyo.
Just 15 or 20 minutes drive
from where I'm standing right now.
It's one of the best airports
to fly into in Japan
because of its centralized location.
Right on the bay.
And you have a beautiful view of the city
when you fly in.
But on this very busy day,
a day
that hours after Japan
was rocked by a massive earthquake,
you had this Coast Guard crew,
six people on the plane total
trying to get relief supplies
to areas hard hit
that desperately need the help.
And at the same time, you had a packed
Japan Airlines jet
that was arriving from Sapporo,
which was
right in the prime
of their tourist season up there
on the northern Japanese
island of Hokkaido.
This plane had 367 people on board,
including eight children
under the age of two.
So you had parents with their kids.
You had 12 crew members
and a fully packed plane.
And just before six P.
M local time,
as this aircraft
was landing on the runway,
the Coast Guard aircraft
was also on the same runway.
How did that happen?
That is the focus.
I'm going to be the focus
of an extensive investigation
here in Tokyo,
a nation that prides itself
on public transportation safety,
a nation
that's never had a single fatality,
and decades of running bullet trains
and hundreds of miles an hour.
And yet somehow,
for whatever reason, that reason
to be determined.
These two aircraft
had a very, very violent collision
that resulted in a huge fireball.
Both of the plane
planes were in flames
in a matter of seconds.
And passengers
who were on the Japan Airlines jet
describe black smoke filling the cabin.
They were terrified parents
trying to keep their kids
as safe as they could,
wondering if they were going
to make it out alive.
A lot of passengers saying
they just didn't think that they would,
especially when the exit doors
according to the passengers in the rear
and middle parts of the aircraft,
were not working properly.
But yet through the front exit doors
and there's video of this
that's emerging on social media
people one by one
streamed out of each side
of the front of the aircraft.
And in just a matter of seconds,
all 400 or so people
who were on that aircraft
made it off alive.
17 of them in the hospital with injuries.
But an extraordinary thing
when you look at the video of that plane
that was
then very quickly fully engulfed
in flames still smoldering on the runway.
It took firefighters
well over an hour
to get the fire under control.
Haneda Airport, a very busy hub,
of course,
shut down right now
and likely to be shut down
for quite some time
as they investigate
exactly how this happened,
as they look into the cause of this.
But still,
the fact that so many people,
hundreds of people
were able to walk away
even as Japan mourns
the loss of these five Coast Guard
crew members,
it is truly a remarkable moment
at the beginning of 20, 24,
which has been very rough for Japan,
given the earthquake first
and then
this collision on the runway
right in the heart of the Japanese
capital town.
Yes, certainly
this a really dark period for Japan.
But as you say, just remarkable
that hundreds of people
were able to escape those flames.
Will Ripley live for us there in Tokyo.
Will, thank you.
All right.
With us now, CNN aviation
correspondent Pete Montaigne.
And Pete,
when you look at those pictures,
when you see that plane in flames,
it's a near miracle
that everyone on board
was able to get out.
What do you see
when you look at what I see
and you see the impact there
in the first 2 seconds of that video
is really a wakeup call,
not only for aviation in Japan,
but also around the world
and especially in the United States.
We'll get to that in a second.
Japan Airlines Flight five, 16.
This was a Airbus A350,
only two years old,
came in to land on runway 34
right there at Haneda.
What is interesting here
is that we know
from the track of the plane
that this plane was coming into land
and the plane behind it had to go around.
We do not know the track
specifically because
there's no data available from that.
Japan Coast Guard Dash eight airplane,
six people on board,
five of them are dead.
We know that the captain of that flight
is in critical condition.
What is really striking to me is the
communication and the coordination
by the crew that made this evacuation.
So, so successful.
Not just the pilots,
but all of the crew,
the flight attendants,
especially Japan, prides itself
on efficiency.
They got these people out
in a very short period of time.
There you can see the two airplanes
and this big size
difference here, a dash.
It is a much smaller airplane,
although it
clearly did a lot of damage
to the front of that Airbus A350.
This is the first time
an Airbus A350 has ever experienced
a whole loss,
meaning the airplane
is completely destroyed.
What is clear right now
is that there was a huge safety
failure here in a culture
that is incredibly safety conscious.
The Japanese airlines
had a spate of accidents in the eighties
and nineties.
They really cleaned up their act.
But is also clear
is that this was something where
there was an airplane in the wrong place
at the wrong time.
And now the question is
where the confusion took place.
Was it a confusion on the part of air
traffic control
or was it confusion
by one of the crews involved
in that Japan Coast Guard flight
or in that Japan Airlines flight?
So this is something that investigators
really need to look at.
And, of course,
they will listen to the air
traffic control tapes
and the communication there
to see if anything was garbled.
What is really interesting here
in the United States
is that there has been incident
after incident of airplanes
in the wrong place
at the wrong time
on the surface of an airport.
They're known officially
as a runway incursion.
And we have seen seven of these incidents
could so serious
that the National Transportation
Safety Board has been involved.
JFK, Austin, Boston, Burbank,
the list goes on.
This incident
really immediately
reminds me of the Austin incident
where a FedEx flight
was coming into land
at Austin Bergstrom on February.
Southwest Airlines
flight was lined up on the runway
ready to take off.
It was in bad weather conditions.
It was dark.
It was before dawn.
And the FedEx crew caught the error
and went around.
In this case, of course, it was dark.
It was about 5:47 p.m. local time.
Although the weather was pretty good.
And now the question is
whether or not this Japan Airlines
flight crew
was able to see this plane
in front of them and why it was there.
So a lot of big questions
here, and investigators
really have their work
cut out for them John.
Well, let's discuss this more
and get more analysis on this.
Miles O'Brien joining us now
he's a CNN aviation
and aerospace analyst. Miles.
Good to see you today, unfortunately.
Certainly a dark day for Japan.
Well, just your initial read,
I mean, what do you think happened here?
Well,
you know, there are
many, many layers of safety
built into the system.
And we got down to the absolute last
layer here.
And this one, which was
the possibility of an orderly evacuation.
And I don't want to
I think we can't underscore enough
how successful that evacuation was.
The crew did a great job
getting them off.
And if any group of people collectively
would listen to a flight crew
and do what
they're told
and follow the rules,
it is the people of Japan,
anybody who's lived there and knows
the culture there.
They do, in fact,
listen to rules and follow rules
so that was really fantastic.
And that was a great demonstration
of the possibilities there.
The other thing to think about here
real is
there have been decades of work
on the part of the FAA
and other organizations
to reduce the flammability
of the materials
that are inside the cabin of an aircraft
And this is an example here,
I think, of the success
there, that it holds off
potential danger
from the toxic fumes and the flames.
Enough time
to get passengers off
if they listen to the rules.
So we can take that away as a half full
look at it.
But clearly,
there is some
dramatic failure in the system here
which will have to be
identified and worked on.
And how do they do that?
I mean, once they identify
the causes
here,
walk us through
how they officially investigate this.
Well, you've got three main parties here.
You've got the flight crew aboard
the Airbus A350.
You have
apparently the surviving pilot,
the Coast Guard
pilot on the Dash
eight, the smaller aircraft.
And you have the air traffic controllers
up there in the control tower.
And each of them will have a story.
Now, they'll be interviewed separately.
And of course, on top of that,
what you have
are lots of recordings, recordings,
of the air traffic control communications
and the cockpit voice
recorder on the Airbus A350.
I'm not sure
if that Japanese Coast Guard craft
was similarly equipped.
We'll have to see about that.
But the parties involved,
the people who made the decisions
in this case are all present.
And with us still to sort of sort out
what happened,
where the confusion happened
is, as Pete pointed out,
it was good weather,
but it was nighttime.
It's the busiest airport
in the Pacific Rim
in the middle of a terrible disaster.
A lot of adrenaline
going, I'm sure, with that Coast Guard
crew trying to get
needed relief supplies
up to the stricken region.
So there are a lot
of subtle human factors here
that need to be addressed.
Mm hmm.
Miles O'Brien, we
we appreciate the time
and the insights today.
Thank you, Miles. You're welcome to help.